Your task in this exercise is to set the pivot point for the body and head to
be around the crossbar. Think back to the unit on transforms. We saw how the
snowman's arms could go to the wrong place with a bad order of transforms. If
we translate it then rotate it, the arms would swing wildly in their position
similar to the drinking bird; however, it's a bit trickier than that. The birds
body and head are in the correct spots, so where would be translate them to.
Think about it this way, say we constructed the bird a bit differently. Instead
of moving the body and head to their final location, what if we moved them so
that the center of the cross bar were was at the origin. Then, the body and the
hat would be right location for rotating around the crossbar. We could then put
both parts into an object 3D, such as the body head object, and apply the
rotation to this parent. We could then move the parent to the proper location
after performing the rotation. Your job is to modify the create drinking bird
method so that the pivot is set correctly. I've given you a variable pivot
height which is the height of the cross bar above the origin. I'll also give
you a hint. It should take about 3 lines of code inside just this method to set
the pivot.